the televised Announcement by Poland's
prime minister hardly seemed to ring
true
we are no longer transferring weapons to
Ukraine because we are now arming
ourselves with the most modern weapons
the sixth largest donor of military aid
to Ukraine Poland has handed over tons
of heavy Weaponry including hundreds of
tanks and now implied the Prime Minister
it has nothing left to give
two things lie behind the latest
announcement first an escalating dispute
over grain with Russia targeting
Ukraine's Seabourn agricultural exports
Ukraine has been forced to find other
routes via the European Union farmers in
Eastern Europe have protested against
those cheap Imports leading some
countries including Poland to introduce
Bans
the second fueling the political
rhetoric is Poland's general election
next month the right-wing ruling Law And
Justice party counts Farmers among its
core constituencies
cave has responded by threatening legal
action against Poland and president
felodimir zelenski attending the U.N
general assembly in New York insinuated
on Tuesday that Poland is playing into
Russia's hands and it is alarming to see
how some in Europe so some our friends
in Europe play out solidarity in
political theater making Thriller from
the green
and with that the fracturing of a
relationship that has been among the
most steadfast since the war in Ukraine
began
yes we have elections in Poland so of
course coming so of course the
government the the governing party is
obviously taking you know perhaps rather
hot using rather hot rhetoric but the
truth is it's incomprehensible why now
it's reached the level of the of the
president you know Ukrainian president
why is he be hating Poland as if it was
a country unfriendly country you know he
walked out before the speech of the
Polish president and did not want to
actually organize a meeting that is
something which you know I'm sure will
settle this and those people in the
Kremlin who are kind of opening
champagne we will prove them wrong but
nevertheless this is not helping
analysts seem confident the rift can be
healed but not without Damage Done to
the image of an unshakable alliance
backing Ukraine to the likely Delight of
Moscow Jonah Hall Al Jazeera